[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster now polls open for
council elections across England in just
10 hours time and even if you're
watching in Scotland or Wales and you're
not voting in these elections this is
why you should care is Russia sunax
first test at The Ballot Box as prime
minister so we get to find out whether
he really has it in to turn the toy ship
around avocaustama can he turn that huge
poll lead into something Concrete in
other words is he on the palm number 10.
we'll bring you both the motor parties
the latest polling I want a fascinating
interview with the SMP as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
our memories on on that show we all know
what happened last time where they're in
power there was no money left for the
country
they're bringing up that note left by
Liam Ben back in 2010 you can really
tell it's the final pmqs before a big
set of Elections can't you and there was
more
growth down tax up the economy crashed
Mr Speaker they're gonna need a bigger
note
he knew that one was coming didn't he
you can certainly uh tell that there was
also a few laughs when the S PS leader
in Westminster asked question
in 2010 David Cameron convinced Nick
Clegg to drop his Pledge on University
tuition fees does the Prime Minister
intend to take the credit for convincing
the leader of the labor party to do
likewise
a little bit of an awkward moment we'll
talk about that later plus The Wider
state of the Scottish national party and
we've got some really cracking Getty on
the show tonight including the leveling
up secretary Michael Gove we'll talk to
Labor's chat out leveling up Minister
Alex Norris and the man that you saw
just a few moments ago the snps
Westminster leader that's Stephen Flynn
and much more besides on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
and a good evening well there are plenty
of nervous Council candidates across
England and plenty of nervous
politicians here in Westminster and
strategists at party hqs as well all
waiting to find out what happens and
trying to work out what it means for the
looming general election so let's crack
straight on we can start with the best
bits of the week so far
thousands of nurses in England have
walked out today as part of their
dispute with the government overpay
we just for says Health unions are
ministers where the latest payoffer will
be discussed we've just had this
breaking news the NHS staff Council
today has overwhelmingly accepted the
government's pay deal it's important to
note it was a majority decision not a
unanimous decision everyone now respects
the decision of the NHS staff council is
an opportunity to now come together now
candidates across England are out and
about for a final day of campaigning
ahead of tomorrow's local elections you
know we've all said these are going to
be a tough set of Elections for us we're
concentrating on delivering on people's
priorities to a local level so
kirstalmer will be hoping to get that
red line above the blue line but no
other leader of the low party will do
the conservative party have been able to
turn that into an instant general
election wins are you going to see a big
election losses prime minister not long
to go now until prime minister's
questions and this I guess is the Final
Act of these two gents as they try and
compel encourage vote to put across in
their particular Party Box four years
for the average saver to save nine
thousand pounds or or to put it a
different way in terms of the Prime
Minister will understand roughly the
annual Bill to heat his swimming pool
previously Mr Speaker he did say he's on
record and saying local people local
communities should have more power more
control now he's U-turn just another in
a long list of broken promises
once again things getting pretty
personal there at pmqs we can start this
evening with the government as we keep
saying it is a crucial test for the
conservatives after months of Fairly
disastrous polls a few moments ago I
spoke to the leveling up Minister
Michael Gove
we're gearing up to the local elections
what are you expect him to see well it's
difficult obviously when you're just on
the eve of those elections to state with
definitive certainty what that could
happen the experts has been well
advertised uh rattings and Thrasher the
sort of gurus of polling say that they
expected themselves to lose about a
thousand seats up to a thousand and the
worst case scenario not not that that's
not their understanding predictions and
it is challenging you know all the
points about the the point in the
lifetime of this Parliament and some of
the challenges that we had as a
government last year I think make it
tough but we've got some very good
candidates we've got um a very good
record in local government on everything
from maintenance of our roads the amount
of money that we've devoted to potholes
to keeping Council taxes low to making
sure that when for example big planning
decisions are made that conservatives
make sure that we protect the green belt
and Safeguard the environment and of
course when it comes to recycling as
well uh conservative councils have a
great record when it comes to waste so I
hope that the good work of conservative
councils is rewarded at the polls
tomorrow potholes and bins you know
we're uh we were in a local election
Bingo season and certainly we know that
those are votes are coming up when you
guys start talking about those things
um I spoke to kirstama who said that
actually the conservatives should be
making gains in these elections 2019 he
says was the second worst set of results
ever Theresa may apologize and a few
weeks later resigned and that was the
end of her and he has got a bit of a
point hasn't he I mean you say that look
the experts are predicting up to a
thousand seat losses but they're
predicting that because of how badly you
guys are doing in the polls no I think
uh again Sakia will say one thing one
day and another thing the next in order
to you know uh uh try to well it's been
quite consistent in in saying about your
uh I don't think the labor leader has
been saying that conservatives should be
making gains very often he does it
because he he tacks With The Wind in
order to you know we use a classic
politician I'm getting very confused by
the direction we're going here I'm
asking you about the reason that you are
setting to lose seats at the election is
because of how badly you're doing it and
indeed you you put it in the context of
Kia's Spin and you know he'll say it
better as he always does because of the
political advantage of the moment that
he's seeking but the broader point is
that
um we are uh facing uh a challenge uh
after what was a very difficult year
last year and the one thing I would not
want to see is the good work of
conservative councilors on the ground
affected by the Backwater of what
happened I also think that there is a a
recognition that with a new prime
minister in Rishi sunec with the focus
that he's put on uh Harvey inflation
reducing debt growing the economy
cutting waiting lists and of course
stopping the boats that people will I
hope uh be ready to vote conservative
tomorrow and ready to see us deliver
over the course of the next Euro 18
months it's going to be quite tough in
some of the sort of traditional blue
wall should we say some of the places
like where you represent in Surrey yes I
think it's gonna be a difficult night
and those kind of showers well I think
that there are challenges everywhere and
I think specifically then I think that
we know that there will be uh some
opportunist political parties and
movements that will seek to uh uh
generate or catalyze some of the
challenges that we've had in the past in
order to try to uh to take uh control of
some local authorities
um but ultimately I think that the
record of conservative councils the
efficiency that they've shown I I hope
will be rewarded more broadly though I
would say as the Secretary of State
responsible for local government there
are people in all parties who do believe
in contributing to their communities so
I wish all the candidates well but I
really hope that people will re-elect
conservatives and in Surrey the
conservative uh uh Council record has
been one of uh to my mind you know
superb delivery including in my own
constituency which is one of the most
attractive places in in Britain to do
business
um we I want to talk a bit about housing
you mentioned they're the sort of green
belt uh you've also said previously the
housing market is broken yes and we
desperately need more homes to bring
ownership Within Reach of many more
people are you going to be taking on the
nimbies well I think that it's wrong to
characterize people as nimbies I think
it's insulting to use a phrase like that
I think the the critical thing is we
need to go with the grain of uh what
people want people do want new homes but
they also want new homes which are
beautiful they want the infrastructure
alongside them the investment in schools
hospitals and roads they want to retain
Democratic control and they want homes
that are environmentally uh situated in
the right locations that's why the green
belt is so important I was interested to
hear you say homes are beautiful there
which obviously everyone prefer a
beautiful home but I just wonder about
you know where the line is you know you
recently blocked Barclay homes from
building houses in Kent because they're
generic Suburban what's so bad about
generic Suburban doesn't the prime
Authority need to be getting houses no
the most important thing is to make sure
that we have homes that are quality
dwellings that people can take pride in
and also a quality dwelling but generic
Suburban right no well first of all that
is a specific planning application which
is now being judicially reviewed I can't
go into the detail but there's a very
good letter in the times today pointing
out that actually
um the design code which was adopted by
the local community has to be complied
with and it is important we all believe
in local democracy on the eve of local
elections but local democracy is honored
but more broadly if we simply
concentrate on the quantity of homes
built and don't concentrate on quality
what we risk creating are the slums of
the future you and I both know about
some of the recent tragedies that we've
had in poor quality rented housing poor
quality social housing and in poor
Quality Private rented housing so we
need to make sure that homes are high
quality that they contribute to a sense
of community and the pylama high sell
them cheap approach that we saw in the
1960s
has now unfortunately led to people
being in homes which are just not fit
for purpose you mentioned the rental
market there and one of the biggest
barriers to people getting their home
homes is they can't afford to save up
for them right so you know just looking
in London a third of your wages now most
people's wages are spent on rent rental
prices up 15 on last year what are you
doing about it we're introducing new
legislation it'll be out next week it's
uh renters Reform Bill
um and it will change the way in which
the relationship between landlords and
tenants work providing tenants with new
protection which should ensure that they
are better protected against arbitrary
rent increases are you not worried on
the building homes front as well what
scrapping targets is going to do no I
think that it's a misnomer to say that
we're scrapping targets we we still have
a commitment to 300 000 new homes every
year and what we've done is we've
provided incentives for local
authorities to set achievable targets
taking account of uh the importance of
protecting the environment and if local
authorities do not set an appropriate
number of homes that are built then they
will find that their plans are overruled
by the planning inspector but it's a
more sensitive
nuanced pro-environment pro-democracy
approach
um I want to talk to you a bit about Sue
gray it's been a lot of focus on sugray
the senior civil servant who left to
become kiss Thomas Chief of Staff now
you work with her for many years right
so you know her more the most is she a
woman of Integrity totally so do you
have any concerns about her appointment
yes I do and they relate to kirstalma's
role
um the key thing is kirst armor could
share with the public with akaba and
indeed with the cabinet office details
of all of his contacts with Sue and all
of his team's contacts with Sue and
others he has chosen not to do his
silence condemns him it's unchivalrous
it's untrustworthy it's wrong the
responsibility of stormers at the same
time though you say she's a woman of
Integrity yes you it therefore would I
would imagine believe that she wouldn't
do anything that would be you know
breaking the rules or against the rules
um our political Deputy political editor
Sam Coates saying today that the first
Contact between Sue gray and timer was
in October I mean that's after Boris
Johnson that's after partygate what's
the concern surely you do talk to
somebody before giving them a job well
the person who could clear this up as I
say is Kirsten
um uh he is he is uh the elected figure
the public figure with the
responsibility of having initiated uh uh
this approach and having taken this
decision
um uh he should come clean his failure
to do so suggests to me that he has
something to hide it's up to him
now it's been a pretty difficult time
for civil service the scrutiny of the
sugary appointment there's been of
course the focus around the Dominic Raab
report as well uh the man at the top of
the Civil server some case in the papers
I think more than I can remember anyone
else in that job is that a sustainable
position for him yes I think it's simply
the case that um the the media
environment in which we live
um and I don't think it's just a fact of
life means that there is more Focus
sometimes on individual characters at
particular points and there will be
individual people who will
um uh be you know in the in the pit of
the spotlight of news scrutiny at a
certain point he is in the spotlight and
it's the decisions and the advice that
he's given that has come under question
you know whether it's Sue gray whether
it's Nadim zahawi uh whether it's Boris
Johnson
is this sustainable that he's getting
this constantly in the Press constantly
his decisions being picked over and
questioned yeah I think it's it's uh it
is sustainable and I think it's wrong to
concentrate on uh civil servants in this
way
um I think that the inevitable focus on
whoever was cabinet secretary is a
consequence of the turbulent political
times through which we've been living so
whoever had been cabinet secretary
um would have found themselves because
of a you know a period when you've had
three prime ministers in a relatively
quick succession would have found their
role as the the prime minister's
principal policy advisor among other
things uh held up to the light so he was
a victim I guess of the chaos and the
conservative part is what you're trying
to say I wouldn't say that I think that
we've been living through very turbulent
political times
um but I think that
um uh the cabinet secretary and other
permanent secretaries uh strive to do
their best for the elected government of
the day of course there's going to be
scrutiny of them but my own view is that
we as elected politicians should be
grateful to them for the work that they
do
um and we should appreciate their
commitment to Public Service uh going to
be pledging allegiance to the king this
weekend oh yeah definitely what's your
plans well I'm very fortunate as a
member of the cabinet or certainly as a
member of the cabinet at the moment
um to be invited to the coronation and I
shall uh it's a it's a it's a great
honor and it's it's a moment when our
country comes together it is on the one
hand a a moment of religious and
historic significance but there's also a
chance for us to recognize that
um our history it has been a history
where we've achieved enormous things and
made great progress because there are
also symbols of continuity and so this
country you know the home of the NHS the
country that defeated the slave trade
and defeated fascism we did all that
because our constitutional Bedrock was
Secure the more secure your home the
further you can Venture and in that
sense our royal family the monarchy is a
symbol of that security so I'll be
celebrating the institution as well as
also remembering both the service of her
late Majesty Queen but also the
commitment to so many great causes of
the king not least the environment uh
clearly a bit of a royalist then you've
got any Street parties you're getting a
quiche out what's the uh
um uh later in the day
um I'll be with a few friends and yes we
probably will go mad with the coronation
quiche
Michael guy promised him to go mad with
a coronation quiche I really have no
words to follow uh that uh from him uh
interesting interview and we'll get
Labor's take a little bit uh later uh
but I just wanted to talk to I'd
definitely enter Sam capes uh a little
bit about Sue gray because Sam's been
doing a bit of digging into this story
and I'll be honest I'm trying to work
out how much we should care about this
um Sue gray
long-standing uh civil servants uh of
course headed up the party gate inquiry
into uh Boris Johnson
case Thomas at Chief of Staff or up who
he hopes to be the chief of staff
there's a lot of scrutiny right now
isn't there about that appointment
that's right and back in March in early
March Sky News revealed that this woman
here Sue gray 30-year veteran of the
Civil Service the woman who did the
party gate inquiry into Boris Johnson
was going to work for that man Kia
stammer she's going to be his chief of
staff when she's finally released by The
Civil Service to go and do do so but
there are lots of concerns amongst
conservatives because she knows
everybody's Secrets one of the jobs that
she's had quite recently was out of
propriety and ethics that means she was
the person that ministers had to go to
to confess their conflicts of interest
their sins you'd often decide whether a
minister stayed or when the enemy and
now exactly uh she knows uh the kinds of
things that he wants to know that could
give him some kind of electrical
advantage and that's why Tories are very
worried about this appointment now there
has been a mystery in British politics
for the last two months kirst armor has
refused to say at the point at which he
revealed he was going to employ Sue gray
how long he'd been talking to her for
was it for instance all the way back to
the partygate inquiry days back in the
first half of last year well tonight I
can reveal the answer to this mystery
that has come up time and time and again
the first Contact between these two
people came in October last year now let
me just get my dates uh right on this
okay because it feels like quite a long
time ago because politics has been on
fast forward but that is after Boris
Johnson it's after the party gate
inquiry why didn't Christian just tell
people that so it's not clear they uh
why they didn't come uh public the the
thing that they're waiting for is this
uh body called acaba now that's the
appointment's body to determine when Sue
gray can be released to go and work for
Kirsten at the moment she's on Garden if
she's at home she's effectively kicking
her heels and not doing anything she's
got to wait for akaba to do a report
into what she did and when she can be
released and how much of a conflict of
interest and I think what they're doing
is trying to not get in the way of that
but it doesn't look great it doesn't
look good but at the same time it's
sometime after party gate yes there were
some discussions about what government
would have to do for the inquiry that's
still going on into Boris Johnson so I
suspect some Tories will suggest maybe
they she broke the civil service code
but far from clear that it's quite as
bad as some people thought before
interesting oh certainly at Sam
obviously talking to all the right
people in Westminster to try and keep
her on track of that story you're
watching the take we are live in
Westminster for you today up next we're
going to be talking to the Westminster
leader of the s p lots to talk about
about SNP with Stephen Flynn
[Music]
in the last few months there's been a
dramatic
advance in the power of
um AI in various different ways most
prominently the chat Bots uh chat GPT
has gone through various different
iterations and just in the last few
months and also in a whole range of
other capabilities uh video
um making uh making videos from text
making pictures that look very realistic
like that one of the Pope you might
remember wearing the puffy jacket yeah
yeah so that I mean that's just a a tiny
hint of what's to come uh in terms of
the the realism of the stuff that AI
could produce you should be most scared
about
um Jeffrey Hinson brought this up in his
interviews the existential risk of AI
and that's something which sounds like
it's almost out of a science fiction
film like Terminator or something but it
is possible and Jeffrey Henson is seeing
this that AI could actually end up
wiping out Humanity if we allow it to
become too powerful and that you know
how does that happen uh well over time
we develop AI we develop it into a much
more intelligent uh
um being phenomenon whatever you want to
call it than us and we start giving it
power in various different ways we start
giving access to uh energy we start
giving access to financial transactions
we start giving access to weapons and
this might happen from uh you know
actors that are not necessarily you know
responsible this might happen right you
know countries using it for uh war and
and so on
um and if it becomes more intelligent
than we do and if it becomes uh able to
improve itself and able to kind of
trick humans and be more intelligent
than them we could end up in a situation
like we're in with I don't know
chimpanzees where they
can't possibly comprehend our intentions
and we allow them to exist because uh
because we because we want to but we
need it necessarily
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
well we can turn now to the Scottish
national party and it has been frankly
two months of utter turmoil for the
party and today the s p at Westminster
confirmed it had finally been able to
appoint Auditors amid investigations
into the party's finances a little
earlier I spoke to the s p Westminster
leader Stephen Flynn
just want to start with your question at
pmqs uh saying that David Cameron
Commons Nick Clegg to drop his Pledge on
University tuition fees does the PM
intend to take the credit for convincing
the leader at the labor party to do
likewise I mean it sounds a bit like one
of those planted questions you get from
the government benches I've very much uh
not the case um what I was I was seeking
to do there was just to highlight the
absurdity of Libra's position you know
kirst armor when he became labor leader
came in with a number of pledges that
you made to the the Libra membership and
ultimately pledges to the public as well
and he's running again on many of them
not least the one in relation to free
tuition and that's really helpful for
the conservative point when just look at
the response from Rishi sunak I Thank
The Honorable gentleman for the question
it is hard to keep up with the list of
broken promises well I I think in
relation to this particular issue
there's a clear divide in line between
the Scottish national party and the
labor party of course in Scotland under
the the Scottish government led by by
Honda Yusuf we have free tuition it's
why I'm sat here today because I was one
of the very many beneficiaries uh of
that as so many other people have been
and now we have a labor leader who's
seeking to elicit change who wants to
get young people to Aspire for a better
future who's seen his pledge which he
made to them a very important pledge now
no longer matters he doesn't want to
abolish tuition fees and match the match
the priorities of the s p but you can
see why you're really going for kirst
armor here right and the richest United
may think it's actually quite uh helpful
I mean are you a little bit worried that
you know SMP supporters looking at the
state of your party right now might
switch to the labor party I'm old enough
to remember when they were the largest
part in Scotland well well I think
there's been a lot of speculation in
relation to that but the point of my
question today was to highlight that
it's the SNP who are looking to protect
young people's futures and as the SNP
Who deliver free tuition for for people
in Scotland and that's not just that's
not just a slight the concern the labor
party it's like the conservatives as
well and indeed the lab dams and the
whole point of that was was to structure
the fact that you know Westminster is
the one that's taken us out of the
European Union you have the three big
political parties uh in Westminster
three established Westminster parties
want to go back in who want to limit the
opportunities for young people and here
we have it again when it comes to to
education and you have the Tories the
labor party in the lab dams if you don't
want to give young people that
opportunity that the SNP have given
young people and I think that's a clear
dividing line between the the Scottish
national party and all those parties not
just a labor party not just a tourists
not just a dance but all of them I guess
you know if you were a voter or swing
boat in particular looking at s p right
now though you might think look are
these guys really competent enough to
manage
other people's money when they can't
manage their own I mean you have been
scrambling to meet a deadline right and
to get the Auditors in to access this
money yeah it's been a great look at it
so so it's I don't think anyone can or
will shy away from the challenges that
we've faced internally uh or obviously
the parties had its issues
um north of the border and down here
we've had challenges in relation to
meeting the audit deadline I'm actually
delighted that we can now uh confirm
that we have an auditor in place and
we're looking forward to to getting that
deadline which is the end of May uh hit
because it's important that we have
access to that to that resource in order
to pay our staff and they've been at the
the Forefront of this discussion and I
think some of the politics around it has
been a bit uncomfortable in that regard
because it was their jobs their
livelihoods and the support that they
provide us that we were seeking to
protect I mean what is going on like you
say it's we're talking about missing out
on 1.2 million having to let people go
well well of course that we're not going
to be letting anyone going we're going
to hit them
it was very it was very challenging and
you know I I found out in February um
about the situation the fact that we
didn't have an order since then we've
been trying to secure one we've done
that now and but there's been challenges
did you only find out February I mean
you must how did you react when you
first find that out well I I think when
I first found out I didn't actually
think it was a huge deal because I
thought it would be quite
straightforward to go and secure a new
order or that obviously didn't prove to
be the case but now we've got one I'm
I'm just delighted to go over that and
we can get back to talking about
politics I guess the issue is does it
feed into wider concerns about the s p
and management of money your party is
subject to a fraud investigation north
of Border we've seen people being
arrested you know forensic tents outside
houses
motorhomes being seized I mean a lot of
people will be looking at this it sounds
like something out of a TV drama after
they trust the s p I think those those
individuals that have obviously been
um they've been contacted by the police
now would be a mess of me to delve to
delve into that but look we need to get
a house in order humza's done a lot up
till now in relation to that we've got a
governance review in place and I'm
looking forward to the outcome without
coming forward because we need to be in
a better place internally as apparently
as a member it's frustrating for me to
know and to learn some of these things
in the media and to obviously learn
about things uh after the fact I don't
think that's that's helpful and I think
across our membership that's how we feel
but look we've been in government uh for
a long time and the reason we've been in
government for a long time these people
of Scotland trust us to deliver for them
and situation fees as a clear example of
where we have done things differently
we've done things better and we'll
continue to do that it's interesting
you're saying that how you felt
frustrated as a member to be I guess
kept out the loop of things do you think
that's been like a culture of secrecy uh
I think what we've seen since hamza's
came in is certainly more openness more
transparency and I think that's a good
thing I've tried to be as upfront as I
possibly can on all of these things as
well so was it open and transparent
before then I think people can read
between the lines and assess the fact
that if members of the party I don't
even think the deputy leader of the
party uh was aware of certain aspects of
of things that had happened I don't
think that's that's helpful
um but we have a new leadership team in
place homes has really focused on making
sure that we resolve these problems
we've got the governance review in place
he's been very open very forthright with
the with the media on on all of the
queries in relation to these things and
we need to keep that going because what
matters most of them politics is trust
and the public need to trust us they've
they've placed our trust in us for a
long long time and we need to make sure
that they continue to do so into the
future we wrong to place your trust in
the Clusters on them
and she let you down uh no I mean I
I know what you're kind of trying to
allude to here and in relation to some
of the challenges within the party but
you know Nicholas dungeon led us to
election Victory after election Victory
she was she was supremely talented and
supremely successful could things have
been done differently in terms of the
way the property operates in that
respect I think everyone would probably
nod their head and say yeah it probably
should have been done differently um but
I'm just doing things differently that's
a good thing I've been really impressed
by him up till now I think he's
certainly uh gone down well with the
public back home as well and hopefully
we can go on to positive new days
because you know what a lot of people
are were projecting the demise of the
Scottish national party that that ain't
happening we're just getting started you
speak very highly obviously of your new
leader Hamza Yusuf he has said it's been
in his words I think I can say this on
TV uh bloody frustrating it hasn't been
the ideal honeymoon for him no it's not
um but but look at what he's managed to
achieve in those six weeks he's managed
to put forward his own prospectus uh for
government and around the quality and
opportunities to reset our relationship
with business which was badly needed
he's reset his relation ship with
businesses in northeast of Scotland
energy and businesses which is very
important from my perspective he's put
cost of living at the very Forefront of
everything that he's doing he's had a
number of policy pledges up until now in
relation to providing support for those
who are in dire circumstances
circumstances created by people down
here in Westminster who've cashed the
entire UK economy and the Scottish
government's having the time pick up the
pieces where where it can he had an
anti-poverty uh Summit today which shows
that his he's focused on meeting the
challenges that that are there for the
people of Scotland and whilst he's been
doing all that he's also been sorting
out things within the party you know it
took us six months to to get an auditor
of to look for an order in six weeks how
many use of delivered one uh you know
that's that's the manner of what he's
achieved now I'm really excited about
what's coming in the future I was quite
interested to see his comments on free
School meals uh in Scotland he was
saying look he's got a child uh who is I
can't remember the exact age but in
school there you go is it right for
other people to be paying for meals for
his children well what's your take on
that so what he was referring to there
was the the free skill meals that
existence gone so at this moment in time
most of the Year groups in Primary
School are covered and we're looking to
expand that to primary six and primary
seven which is a really good thing and
as I understand it I think there's many
pilot schemes in relation to secondary
schools as well but we then need to have
that discussion about what does that
look like in secondary schools and as
part of that I mean we don't just need
to reflect upon how much money families
have in their pocket but also what the
habits are of people in secondary school
because I'm sure you like me uh your
habits change some the older you got but
at the heart of this is the fact that
the SNP in Scotland whether it's free
tuition whether it's uh free School
meals whether it's free prescriptions
whether it's lower council tax so on and
so forth we've been at the Forefront of
providing Progressive policies and we'll
continue to do that
see coronation this weekend are you
going to be pledging allegiance to the
king I believe I already have
and how are you going to be celebrating
uh I'll be there I'll be there on
Saturday
um look I'm I'm not a monarchist I've
been quite open about that in the past
um but I represent everyone uh and all
communities in Scotland so I'll be there
on their behalf to to make sure that
they're represented because that's the
that's the right thing to do it's it's
the grown-up thing to do and I'll
obviously be there with the first
minister of Scotland as well if there's
an independent of Scotland do you think
King Charles should be the Monarch I
think it's important that the people of
Scotland if they want to change have the
opportunity to change that applies to
everything and not just the monarchy not
just the Constitution but all aspects of
things nothing nothing should be um out
the reach of the Scottish people when it
comes to deciding what their
constitutional future so a potential
referendum then on the monarchy of the
people of Scotland so so wanted that to
be the case and but you know what I
think is important is to recognize the
fact that we do have a head of state and
whilst we've got a head of state they'll
have my respect okay thank you very much
good to talk
I thought that was a pretty revealing
interview uh actually uh when you were
when he was talking a bit about the
culture within the s p read between the
lines about whether it was open and
transparent previously now it's just
absolutely typical isn't it you do an
interview with the SMP Westminster
leader and a few minutes later
pre-blockbuster poll then comes out
about the SMP so here it is and it is
not pretty reading I have to say for
Stephen Flynn all for humza uh Yusuf you
can have a little look at this poll uh
here it's a New Westminster voting
intention poll in Scotland showing that
support for the SMP has fallen to its
lowest vote share in any UK general
election poll by any pollster since
2014. now it actually put the rsmp this
is a current uh voting intention putting
the s p there down at 35 with labor
absolutely snapping on their heels up to
32 the conservatives on 18 and now if
you check back this is the 2019 general
election results that's the s p fully
down 10 percent uh from what happened in
the 2019 election just look at that
labor figure as well uh Coastal has been
pretty happy with this one and this new
poll on Scottish independence also
showed that support for Independence uh
down as you can see here this is a blue
line support for Independence down to
just 42 with no leading by fully 10 on
52 there so two uh pretty interesting uh
polls and of course there'll be really a
read through to what happens at the
general election Kirsten and the labor
party hoping to take advantage of some
of the recent terminal in the s p
you're watching the take live in
Westminster up next we are going to be
taking a closer look at pmqs and also
hearing from labor
[Music]
foreign
hello welcome back live to Westminster
this is the take well we can take a
closer look now at this afternoon's PM
Keys and couldn't you just tell there's
an election happening in a day's time
because a labor leader Kirsty sunak over
the course of living crisis at the PM
accused labor of having a long list of
broken promises they're really hitting
those pre-election lines aren't they
here's pimq's unwrapped with Joe Pike
with local elections in the air
provincial politicking dominated today's
session including kierstama's last ditch
pitch to voters he tried to tie
Richardson to the Fallout from Liz
truss's economic policies and the
consequences for homeowners does the
Prime Minister know how many mortgage
payers are paying higher rates since the
Tory party crashed the economy last
Autumn the question was how many people
are paying more on their mortgages each
month and the answer that the Prime
Minister avoided giving is 850
000 counting the cost of the torah's
economic vandalism with every mortgage
payment they make
the labor leader claimed average
first-time buyers would need to raise an
extra nine grand for their deposits
he reinforces just how out of touch he
is
nine thousand pounds hahaha nine
thousand pounds would take four years
they think it's funny you're funny the
Heckler shouted four years four years
for the average saver to save nine
thousand pounds or or to put it a
different way in terms the Prime
Minister will understand roughly the
annual Bill to heat his swimming pool
Mr sunac strategy was surprisingly
similar pouncing not just on the record
of the politician opposite but that of
his predecessors
we all know what happened last summer
they're in power there was no money left
for the country
but let's let's talk about let's talk
about the record let's talk about the
labor record on house building Mr
Speaker in London the former
conservative mayor built 60
000 affordable homes in his first five
years in office how many do the current
labor labor mayor manage half of that Mr
Speaker
responded to the Tory jibe about Liam
Burns no money left letter with this
Jaws related pun
yeah
and it's right as you can see that gag
received a bit of a mixed response in
the chamber Richardson tried to slip in
a jibe about Labor ditching its pledge
to scrap tuition fees in England but
where the PM struggled on that topic the
smp's Westminster leader succeeded
in 2010 David Cameron convinced Nick
Clegg to drop his Pledge on University
tuition fees does the Prime Minister
intend to take the credit for convincing
the leader of the labor party to do
likewise
I Thank The Honorable gentleman for the
question
I'd say it's it's hard to keep up Mr
Speaker with a list of broken promises
and when Stephen Flynn said this was the
party's Nick Clegg moment just look at
the body language on the labor front
bench elsewhere the speaker knocked over
his own glass of water with his robe
watch the reactions in this replay and
we had an almost endless stream of back
benchers asking about local councils the
conservative LED solihull Council lived
them controlled Three Rivers district
council local conservatives tomorrow's
local elections are important not just
because it'll decide who's in charge of
things like bin collections adult social
care and Children Services but also it's
a great barometer as to the political
weather Nationwide we may get a sign
over who's likely to be crowned the next
PM but if we're honest it may all be
overshadowed by a different coronation
at Jay Pike's analysis there as someone
who's pretty clumsy I have so much
Sympathy for the speaker knocking over
his glass of water there now on our
Sunday program the labor leader Kirsten
was fairly Coy about just how much
progress he expects to make in
tomorrow's local elections although he
said that the government should be
making gains so let's see if we can find
out any more a little earlier I spoke to
the party's Shadow leveling up Minister
Alex Norris
well at pmq today
um kissed armor got a bit of a battering
for rowing back on his pledge to scrap
tuition fees are you comfortable with
that
I mean I I don't think that was the pmqs
I watched there were some very robust
exchanges particularly on on house
building uh that I think uh clearly the
Prime Minister seems to be on
exceptionally Shaky Ground on you know
kids made his case as he has recently
with his five missions and you know I
think we're on very comfortable
territory in terms of the the respective
Visions being set out for the country
I just want to go through uh what
Kirsten said when he was running to be
labor leader this is to Andrew Neal he
said we remain committed to scruffing
tuition fees they're all pledges so the
answer to that question is yes and then
he was asked so University institution
fees being scrapped will be in astama
Manifesto and he said yes
you know as you know Sophie that took
place in what the spring 2019 since then
we've had you know two years of a global
pandemic we've had a war on the
continent of Europe we've had the Tories
crash the economy so the equation is
slightly different here is committed
have you seen through our missions to
remove the barriers to opportunity and
funding and education is one of them
we're very very clear that the system is
unfair and needs to be changed but we
will make and you know as you know we're
we're making those preparations ahead of
a general election we will make a very
strong offer about making a much fairer
system than we have at the moment and
one that crucially balances that need
with the nation's finances I think
that's what the public would expect a
responsible labor parties to do and
that's what kirstan was offering
it was made a few years ago and the
world's changed since then as you say
but I guess the problem is the world
could change again right how do we know
that what you guys are saying now is
gonna actually happen if labor get
elected there's a trust issue
you know what you'll get from us is a
fully costed well set out Manifesto when
the election you know is is on its way
so you know of course there can be
changes even with an election campaign
but in that moment you will you'll have
a very clear sense of what we want to do
for this country I think that's the
responsible way to do it you know we
know that people want to see from labor
not a laundry list of of all the things
that we want to do for the country of
course there are lots of things we tried
that election in 2019 and and the public
were very clear about how they felt
about that instead what we'll have is a
clear fully costed affordable impactful
and Progressive Manifesto that will
change Britain for the better ending the
sticking past Buster politics we've seen
of recent years but real change in the
country through proper Mission and
driven based ways cutting crime
improving public services and creating
better opportunities that's what the
public will get from us and they'll be
able to make that judgment based on that
but let's talk about the local elections
uh shall we because things are really
hotting up in that race and kirst armor
told me on Sunday that the conservative
should be making games in these sets of
local elections now I've heard of
expectation management that's not really
realistic is it
I mean how could it be anything else
Sophie you know the let's read back to
when the equivalent elections were last
for which was May 2019 after that
results were so bad for the conservative
party that shortly after Theresa May
resigned we can't honestly be saying
that Rishi sunax not going to do better
indeed might even do worse as the Tories
are saying then that will what would
that say about this uh The sunak Surge
we've been hearing about so you know if
Richie really is the answer and despite
being you know second choice of Tory MPS
second choice of Tory members you know
if he really is the right man to leave
this country will surely he'll be making
significant progress on where Teresa may
finish
see you next Serge I'm not sure if I've
heard that one before
um also the whole thing is though that
the projections that we're looking at
are because the conservatives are in a
position where they should lose seats
because you just have to look at the
polls and you know labor clawing their
way back from one of your worst ever
election defeats I mean that's where we
are not to mention the fact that they're
also defending the most number of
councils and Council seats as well let's
get real they're not going to be making
games
well as I say if if they're not making
gains what does that say about where
they are it says that where Teresa may
finished which is you know considered I
certainly think Boris Johnson and his
supporters would say a real nadir for
the conservative party if they're doing
worse than that then that I think has
real questions about where they are I
mean obviously we're of course focusing
on on our campaign we fought a really
positive one around the cost of living
around improving public services so
we're hoping that that our candidates
are going to do really well
what would be a good night for labor
there what are you hoping for
well I mean you know we we are really
optimistic we're looking to gain seats I
think the thing for me is particularly
the where rather than the Watts you know
if we're going to read this with with an
eye on on the next general election
which of course naturally we're going to
we're all going to be doing that then we
will be looking at the places that we
need to do well in in order to uh win
power and win the next general election
so we'll be looking to see if we've
gained seats in places like that you
know I look out the window and about 30
meters away so the red walls of course
will be looking at places like
brockstone gedling and Beyond and
Nottingham shooting to Derbyshire so
we'll be looking at those and and hoping
we're showing that we're making the
impact there that we want to be doing I
mean that's the point isn't it if you
are going to be using these local
elections to map over across to the
general election you need to be doing
more than pick up a few seats if you've
got to seriously show that you're a
government in Waiting you need to be
picking up hundreds of these
well as I said I I think the the Top
Line number can be a fooler so you know
take Nottingham for example you know we
currently have 50 out of 55 counselors I
very much hope on Friday we get up to 55
we've fought for all of those seeds and
if that happens well we'll have gained
five and the Tories will have lost two
so a change of seven seats well that
sounds like quite a lot I don't think it
would tell us any more about the general
election we already hold three uh
parliamentary seats in the city so you
know as I say I don't think it's that
Global number I think it's the where and
I think we'll soon be able to look at
those areas and to make that judgment as
to whether we're making the progress we
want to be making
finally I've done a bit of a bit of
ducking um in my time going alongside at
Labor and conservative Dems I should say
rather than campaigning actually for a
political party and I have to say you do
see some quite strange things on the
campaign Trail I've seen quite a few
naked people for a start what's the
weirdest thing you've seen on The
Campaign Trail yeah I'm gonna leave
aside all uh nudity uh ones because
though I think they were common for most
canvases mine's a parrot and there's a
picture doing the rounds of me in 2017
of me having a very detailed discussion
with the parrot I didn't get the parrot
support I think I got the owners on that
day
um but yeah that I think that's the most
memorable one I've had that is a good
one definitely thanks very much for
being on the program today thank you
and have a little bit of local election
uh campaigning genuinely the stuff that
you see out and about knocking on doors
is really something else you're watching
the take we are going to be looking at
what tomorrow's local elections could
mean for a general election that's
coming up next
foreign
[Music]
Pages as they arrive there's a feeling
amongst some commentators that it's not
the most respectful timing there's word
fake news I mean it's
delving deeper into the stories with
different perspectives on tomorrow's
headlines we really haven't seen the
government getting around the table and
negotiating there are no easy answers to
those questions the breast preview
delivering you tomorrow's news tonight
on Sky News
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we've heard the expectation management
game from labor from the conservatives
we can get a bit more towards the tree
shall we at with Sam coats because both
all parties try to spin at their lines
of course
somehow do you think the atmosphere
issue we say so we gear up to the big
Vape
well I've just come for an event with
Rishi sudak and he's been playing down
the conservative chances and saying that
it's going to be a difficult night
tomorrow night but really all the nerves
in Westminster feel that they're much
more on the labor side they're the party
with the most approved with the most to
lose because case nominees that if he's
got any chance of going back into Power
taking the labor party into government
he's got an enormous mountain to climb
that's so isn't it because it does feel
like we talk a lot about Labor's pole
lead but actually if you look at the
comparison to the last election they
have got a huge swing that they need to
make right if they're going to get any
chance well here we go as if right on
cue this is your swing armor so just
talk us through what's going on here
because remember Sophie they need to get
124 seats the labor party to uh together
the overall majority of two now if the
result the next general election is
exactly the same as the last general
election uh then uh the line would go
down here and really we are expecting
labor to do better than they did last
time around now you can see here that
it's not that hard for kids armor to
basically take the Tories overall
majority kick the Tories out of Downing
Street and that would only take a three
percent swing but it gets really hard
after that seven percent swing which
would be the second highest uh in this
since the second world war really uh
would uh take labor to being the largest
party they need a 12 swing for it to be
uh to have an overall majority now that
is bigger than Tony Blair got in 1997 in
order to get that 179 majority and that
wouldn't give them a majority of two
seats so you see the kind of Swing uh
here that they are expected to get
that's why comparisons with 1995 are in
play that's why they're gonna have a
very difficult job to spin on Thursday
night that's really interesting isn't it
to say that even if they're gonna get uh
the slimmest of majorities they need a
Tony Blair style uh swing or if you say
really interesting
um I and just want to know where you're
particularly looking out for because
look we're gonna look at what happens on
Thursday and extract to the election
right so there any particular areas that
you're looking at Swindon Derby and
Portsmouth there we go really
interesting so perfect we're gonna look
out for those on Thursday and Friday
Sam's gonna be up all night overnight
I'm going to be at taking over from
Friday alongside so plenty to tune in
for we'll be back next week and every
week Wednesday is 9pm
[Music]
foreign